Fifty percent of high school students don’t
go on to higher education.
Of the 50 percent that do, 43 percent of them
don’t graduate.
Of those that do graduate the average graduation
time is six years.
The average age of a current college student
today is about 25.
And I think 25 percent of college students
today actually have a child.
So if you ask me those statistics suggest
two things.
The current system is not producing what it
was designed to produce for the types of people
that go, the number of people that go and
what they need.
And it has not kept up with the modern world
in terms of how it makes itself available
and what it charges students to be able to
get what they need.
So it’s a combination of availability; It
doesn’t seem to work for the majority of
students, because the number one reason that
students don’t go on to further education
or drop out of college, it’s a combination
of two things which essentially means the
same thing: It’s too expensive, or they
can’t get the classes at the time of day
they’re available.
And that’s because: of the 70 percent of
kids that go to state schools, 40 percent
of them work 30 hours a week or more.
All of this is to say that schools are no
longer programmed at the right time.
They take too long.
They’re too expensive, and what they program
is incomplete.
It’s not necessarily bad.
our view is the education system needs to
evolve to the way we do everything.
Everything we do today comes to us (rather
than us go to them).
An example, today we would never wait out
in the rain for a car and hope that we can
get a cab.
We’ll just hail Uber and it comes and it
takes us exactly where we want to go.
Today we wouldn’t go rush home to watch
a TV show at eight o’clock on a Thursday
night.
We watch it on the device we want to watch
it, when we want to watch it, when it’s
convenient for us.
Only education continues to require you to
come to it, pay a fortune to do it, and have
it be a choice between eating or reading or
learning and earning.
And so what Chegg is trying to do is reverse
it, is try to say let’s use what the internet
does best.
Let’s make it online, on demand.
Let’s make it personalized.
You do it the way you want to do it, not the
way it’s taught singularly to everybody.
Adaptive which means when we watch what you
do and we learn about you, let’s actually
adjust how we teach you or what we teach you,
what we give you more of and what we give
you less of based on your actual abilities.
And then let’s make it exceptionally affordable.
And if we do that you’d be amazed how many
students need to learn, want to learn, are
willing to learn.
So we think that the modern university system
has become too expensive; incomplete programming,
inconvenient locations, inconvenient time
of day for the modern workforce which doesn’t
have the time to do both.
So even if you look at for-profit colleges
they were a mess because they became a scam
for a lot of people.
But if you realize 3.6 million people at one
time were actually taking it, you realize
the demand was there to be able to learn in
your own environment in your own way.
Why?
Because the average person was a 30-year-old
woman who could not leave her family or her
workforce, or in some cases both.
So I just think that the modern education
system needs to acknowledge who the modern
student is, what the demands on that modern
student are—there’s more of them, they’re
more broke, they have more diverse needs.
They enter the system with different education,
different backgrounds, different financial
situations, and no “one size fits all”
is going to work anymore.
And so what we’ve got is we’ve got a lot
of schools – now we’re not talking about
the top 50 or 100 schools.
Those schools have huge endowments.
They’ll be protected for a long time and
they’ll probably continue to be able to
teach the smaller part of the population that
can take four years.
But the ramifications are—well, here’s
a question for you.
Why is there something called a four year
school?
Why does college take four years?
That’s a random number.
Why does a certain course take two years?
It has to do with how many classes they’re
willing to program that you’re able to take.
Not how long it takes you to learn the material.
Ninety-five percent of the time that you’re
at a four year college you’re not in a classroom
in any way, shape or form.
In today’s world we binge watch everything
that we want.
You can binge watch entire series, albums,
learn anything you want.
Why can’t you binge learn your education?
If you’re willing to put in the time at
nights, weekends, days, whatever it is and
learn and master the subject, why can’t
you finish when you’ve learned the things
you’re supposed to learn in order to get
you a job?
So the ramifications are colleges are going
to have to take less time to get somebody
from learning to earning.
There is no reason why it should take four
years.
Very little of the population has the time
or the finances to delay earning by four years.
Only a small subset do.
And so I think the ramifications are you’re
going to see fewer colleges, you’re going
to see them combined, more of them are going
to have to get online.
They’re going to have to expand their curriculum
to include job skills, and I think you’re
going to see a resurgence of institutions
that primarily serve people online.
Not because—a teacher can make the argument
there’s nothing better than one-on-one in
a classroom.
That may be true.
That may be true for a lot of kids.
It’s certainly not true for everybody.
But it’s also 100 percent not available
to anybody.
Nobody gets to learn one-on-one in a classroom
anymore.
And so our opinion is it’s unfair to say
“Because this is the best way, we’re not
going to do the other way” when 90 percent
of the people have no access to the best way.
So if education is really going to grow, it’s
really going to proliferate, it’s got to
be online, increasingly.
It’s got to be on demand.
It has to be multimodality.
Some people learn by taking tests.
Some people learn by watching videos.
Some people learn by human intervention and
human help.
All of those ways need to be available.
There’s no benefit in teaching somebody
who learns this way, this way over here if
that’s not going to work for them.
And when you look at the scores 43 percent
drop out, they drop out with $7,000 to $9,000
in debt.
The ones that survive have $37,000 in debt.
So I mean you just look at the math and ask
yourself, do you want to put your kid into
that system?
The answer has to be no.
Why are we taking the most valuable people,
the future of this country and delaying their
ability to be productive in the workforce,
delaying their ability to make money, and
saddling them with debt larger than anything
else they may do in their life (with the exception
of buying a home), and doing it at 18 years
old?
To me it just sounds unfair and unfortunate.